Katrina:  土豆侠吃土
Katrina: Potato man eats dirt.
Jake:放沙发上
Jake: Put it on the sofa.
Alice: 他够不到
Alice: He can't reach it.
Alice: 我们挪一下啊
Alice: Let's move it a bit.
Alice: 那边还有一个
Alice: There's another one over there.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  我靠 6张披萨
Shure: Whoa, 6 pizzas.
Tasha: 天不是吧
Tasha: No way.
Lucia: 哎哎为什么会是6个披萨呢
Lucia: Hey, hey, why do we have 6 pizzas?
Jake: 买2赠2啊
Jake: Buy 2, get 2 free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Alice: 啊现在有那个活动
Alice: Ah, they have that promotion now.
Lucia: 但我们不是买了
Lucia: But didn't we buy...
Lucia: 就是我还以为是我们买4个
Lucia: I thought we bought 4 and got 2 for free.
Lucia: 其中有两个是送的呢
Lucia: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Alice: No.
Alice: 不行
Alice: I want to put it here.
Alice: 我想在这
Alice:
Katrina:  从未打过这么富裕的仗
Katrina: Never had such an abundance before.
Katrina:  这么多箱子
Katrina: So many boxes.
Jake: 对流水席
Jake: Yeah, it's like a banquet.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Katrina:  哦对
Katrina: Oh, right.
Katrina:  可以站在这边站着吃吧
Katrina: Can we stand and eat here?
Jake: 站着吃吧
Jake: Yeah, let's stand and eat.
Jake: 要不就
Jake: Or maybe...
Katrina:  行啊
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  要不我们什么击鼓传花停哪就
Shure: How about we play musical chairs, and when the music stops...
Shure:  哈哈哈就吃哪啊
Shure: Hahaha, where are we eating?
Jake: 那你把你的音箱拿上来
Jake: Then you bring your speaker up here.
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Jake: 手套可以
Jake: Gloves are fine.
Tasha: 嘿嘿机械
Tasha: Hehe, mechanical.
Shure:  没开是吗
Shure: It's not on, is it?
Katrina:  我说开了
Katrina: I said it's on.
Katrina:  我看有多少电量
Katrina: Let me check the battery level.
Katrina:  要不要充一会
Katrina: Should we charge it for a bit?
Tasha: 嗯谢谢
Tasha: Hmm, thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我亮了吗
Katrina: Am I lit up?
Shure:  你亮着
Shure: You're lit up.
Katrina:  他怎么肯定
Katrina: How is he sure?
Katrina:  还挺吓我一跳我们遛一下
Katrina: That really scared me for a moment, let's go for a walk.
Lucia: 三个多余的哈哈哈
Lucia: Three extras, hahaha.
Alice: 可以开始了吗
Alice: Can we start now?
Lucia: 可以尝尝
Lucia: You can try it.
Jake: 我先吃也行
Jake: I can eat first, too.
Jake: 问题不大问题不大问题不大
Jake: No big deal, no big deal, no big deal.
Jake: 一切都充满着变化
Jake: Everything is full of change.
Jake: 哈哈哈问题不大
Jake: Hahaha, no big deal.
Tasha: 早知道点两个榴莲了
Tasha: I should have ordered two durians.
Jake: 子涵喝水
Jake: Zihan, drink water.
Jake: 你喝哪一个
Jake: Which one are you drinking?
Jake: 几号
Jake: Which number?
Katrina:  今天是什么活动
Katrina: What's the event today?
Katrina:  这个怎么会有6个
Katrina: How come there are six of these?
Katrina:  买4赠2
Katrina: Buy 4, get 2 free.
Shure:  买一赠一
Shure: Buy one, get one free.
Tasha: 买3赠3
Tasha: Buy 3, get 3 free.
Tasha: 我刚才想买4个的话是会不会不够
Tasha: I was just thinking, if I buy four, will it be enough?
Tasha: 他这是九寸的
Tasha: This is a nine-inch one.
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm.
Katrina:  连晚饭都解决了
Katrina: Even dinner is sorted.
Jake: 可以
Jake: That's fine.
Jake: 啊你好
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  一会自己操作一下
Shure: Operate it yourself later.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯呐嗯呐
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake: 嗯这边都是什么管家代取了
Jake: Hmm, over here it's all handled by the housekeeper.
Jake: 就是请我
Jake: They just ask me.
Jake: 我让他们取一下吧
Jake: I'll have them pick it up.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Lucia: 谢谢
Lucia: Thanks.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 那我告诉你号码还是什么呀
Jake: So, should I tell you the number or what?
Alice: 要榴莲的吗
Alice: Do you want durian?
Jake: 53愈合期
Jake: 53, healing period.
Jake: 53还是您
Jake: 53 or you.
Jake: 您要什么呀
Jake: What do you want?
Katrina:  喝了咖啡
Katrina: Drank some coffee.
Jake: 打电话吧
Jake: Make a call.
Katrina:  你的食欲会下降
Katrina: Your appetite will go down.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 好就是我们其实3031栋
Jake: Okay, so actually we are at building 3031.
Jake: 玉河区31栋
Jake: Building 31, Yuhe district.
Jake: 玉河区31 啊
Jake: Building 31, Yuhe district, ah.
Jake: 玉河区31
Jake: Building 31, Yuhe district.
Jake: 佑佑的院子
Jake: Youyou's yard.
Jake: 啊可以可以对
Jake: Ah, yes, yes, right.
Jake: 嗯好嘞好嘞谢谢
Jake: Hmm, okay, okay, thanks.
Tasha: 饱了保护我自己了
Tasha: Full, now I can protect myself.
Katrina:  披萨好管饱的
Katrina: Pizza really fills you up.
Shure:  感觉吃了一半就已经饱了
Shure: I feel like I'm full after eating half.
Tasha: 吃了两片
Tasha: Ate two slices.
Katrina:  带出去野餐吧
Katrina: Let's take it out for a picnic.
Tasha: 嗯带出去野餐吧
Tasha: Yeah, let's take it out for a picnic.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  走累了搞搞个那野餐
Katrina: When we're tired from walking, we can have a picnic.
Katrina:  那一坐就开始吃
Katrina: Sit down and start eating.
Katrina:  吃完又走
Katrina: Eat and then walk again.
Jake: 吃不完带走
Jake: If you can't finish, take it with you.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 再去采风是吧
Tasha: Then go take some pictures, right?
Tasha: 嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, hmm.
Jake: 这个应该可以吃完
Jake: We should be able to finish this.
Tasha: 应该可以吃完
Tasha: We should be able to finish it.
Jake: 不是就是今天的时候
Jake: I mean, today...
Jake: 嗯不会像之前一样丢掉
Jake: ...we won't waste it like before.
Jake: 丢到第二天就没有用了
Jake: It won't be useless by the next day.
Shure:  煤气高钙
Shure: Gas, high calcium.
Shure:  不能浪费食物
Shure: We can't waste food.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice: 瘦了吧唧
Alice: So skinny.
Shure:  看我昨天还看的那个梗
Shure: Look at this joke I saw yesterday.
Shure:  然后就是绑着他强制喂他吃榴莲披萨
Shure: And tying them up to force-feed them durian pizza.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我还以为是
Lucia: I thought...
Lucia: 夏威夷披萨呢
Lucia: ...it was Hawaiian pizza.
Shure:  差不多
Shure: Almost.
Tasha: 榴莲披萨
Tasha: Durian pizza.
Tasha: 这么好吃
Tasha: It's so good.
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No.
Lucia: 就是意大利人看到给披萨上放水果
Lucia: Italians would freak out seeing fruit on pizza.
Lucia: 会非常的崩溃
Lucia: They'd be devastated.
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure:  咱们饺子里面放水果给你吃一样
Shure: It's like putting fruit in dumplings for you.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 他们传统披萨上面是不放水果的
Lucia: Traditional pizzas don't have fruit on them.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure:  肉夹馍突然给你加了一个番茄酱
Shure: Like adding ketchup to a Chinese burger.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Tasha: 没关系我觉得番茄酱蘸什么都好吃
Tasha: It's okay, I think ketchup makes everything taste good.
Lucia: 肉夹馍为什么要放番茄酱
Lucia: Why would you put ketchup on a Chinese burger?
Tasha: 丰富口感吧
Tasha: To enrich the flavor.
Lucia: 异端
Lucia: Heresy.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Adding cheese to Chinese noodles.
Lucia: 臊子面放cheese
Lucia: Cheese on Chinese noodles.
Lucia: 但这我怎么觉得还好
Lucia: But that sounds okay.
Lucia: 还可以接受
Lucia: I can accept that.
Tasha: 我也可以接受
Tasha: I can accept it too.
Jake: 臊子面放cheese
Jake: Cheese on Chinese noodles.
Lucia: 还有美国的那种做成甜了的披萨
Lucia: And those sweet pizzas they make in the US.
Lucia: 好像意大利人也会觉得很崩溃
Lucia: Seems like Italians would also feel devastated.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Mm-hmm.
Tasha: 今天还有布朗尼披萨吗
Tasha: Do we still have brownie pizza today?
Lucia: 你猜吧哦买噶
Lucia: Guess what, oh my god.
Jake: 今晚做一个
Jake: We'll make one tonight.
Tasha: 啊我说达美乐的时候啊
Tasha: Ah, I meant at Domino's.
Jake: 真他有啊
Jake: They really have it.
Tasha: 他有啊
Tasha: They have it?
Lucia: 他有
Lucia: They have it.
Jake: 他真的有
Jake: They really have it.
Lucia: 达美乐有这个味
Lucia: Domino's has that flavor.
Tasha: 布朗尼的
Tasha: Brownie flavor.
Tasha: 还有各种各样甜的披萨
Tasha: And all kinds of sweet pizzas.
Tasha: 吃榴莲吗
Tasha: Want some durian?
Jake: 吃吃吃草本草本谢谢您
Jake: Sure, sure, herbal, herbal, thank you.
Shure:  你好像触发了什么
Shure: Seems like you triggered something.
Shure:  NPC对话
Shure: NPC dialogue.
Jake: 去去去
Jake: Go, go, go.
Shure:  稍等稍等
Shure: Wait, wait.
Lucia: 谢谢你
Lucia: Thank you.
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Jake: 因为
Jake: Because...
Tasha: 他是那天唯一一个点那个榴莲汉堡的
Tasha: He was the only one who ordered that durian burger that day.
Tasha: 跟我一起
Tasha: With me.
Jake: 一些珍贵的人类吃披萨镜头
Jake: Some precious human eating pizza footage.
Lucia: 我
Lucia: I...
Lucia: 眼镜怎么这两天又开始疯狂的往下滑
Lucia: Why do my glasses keep sliding down like crazy these days?
Jake: 这两天瘦了
Jake: You've lost weight these days.
Shure:  真的吗
Shure: Really?
Lucia: 不能吧
Lucia: No way.
Shure:  这都吃瘦了
Shure: Even with all this eating, you lost weight.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 吃瘦了
Jake: Lost weight from eating.
Jake: 太辛苦了
Jake: It's too hard.
Jake: 剧组太辛苦了
Jake: The crew is working too hard.
Shure:  天哪
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure:  我们这剧组
Shure: Our crew...
Jake: 把人这两天把人吃瘦了
Jake: Made people lose weight from eating in just a few days.
Lucia: 哈哈不至于吧
Lucia: Haha, that's not possible.
Shure:  供吃供住
Shure: Providing food and accommodation.
Tasha: 能不瘦吗哈哈哈
Tasha: Can I not lose weight? Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Jake: 这个有问题
Jake: There's a problem with this.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look
Jake: 我记一下
Jake: Let me note this down.
Tasha: 大家只能挤着一起吃披萨
Tasha: Everyone has to squeeze together to eat pizza.
Tasha: 而不是一个人娱乐
Tasha: Instead of enjoying it alone.
Shure:  就是
Shure: Exactly.
Tasha: 就已经已经遭受不公平的待遇了
Tasha: We're already facing unfair treatment.
Jake: 不是就
Jake: It's not just...
Shure:  这段数据要删掉
Shure: This segment needs to be deleted.
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 小心小心你这个
Jake: Be careful, be careful with this.
Jake: 增加我们很多工作量啊
Jake: This increases our workload a lot.
Shure:  对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry.
Jake: 我要记一下
Jake: I need to note this down.
Lucia: 啊什么要删掉
Lucia: Ah, what needs to be deleted?
Lucia: 吃披萨吗
Lucia: Eating pizza?
Shure:  不是
Shure: No.
Tasha: 12.09
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Tasha: 受了不公平的待遇
Tasha: Facing unfair treatment.
Shure:  你看你又说了一遍
Shure: See, you said it again.
Shure:  他又在说
Shure: He's saying it again.
Shure:  逼逼一句
Shure: Blabbering.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Jake: 就这这逼逼逼逼逼的
Jake: It's just this constant blabbering.
Jake: 你们继续吃你们的
Jake: You guys continue eating.
Jake: 但是边吃边逼逼逼
Jake: But keep blabbering while eating.
Lucia: 那
Lucia: Then...
Lucia: 我们之前出现了多少要被道德词汇
Lucia: How many moral words have we used before?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: F word的是不是也要
Lucia: The F word, should we...
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina:  昨天还看到直升机了
Katrina: Yesterday, I even saw a helicopter.
Shure:  啊对
Shure: Oh yeah.
Katrina:  军用的
Katrina: A military one.
Lucia: 对军用的是不是会侵占他的版权啊
Lucia: Yeah, military ones, will they infringe his copyright?
Shure:  看一眼
Shure: Take a look.
Tasha: 我们昨天放的电影
Tasha: The movie we played yesterday.
Tasha: 要不要删掉
Tasha: Should we delete it?
Lucia: 我忘了
Lucia: I forgot.
Shure:  咱们昨天吃火锅没戴眼镜
Shure: We had hotpot yesterday and didn't wear glasses.
Katrina:  哦空调遥控器呢
Katrina: Oh, where's the air conditioner remote?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:完了  又要删了
Jake: Oh no, we have to delete it again.
Katrina:  不想看来着
Katrina: Didn't want to watch it anyway.
Alice: 呵呵
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 没关系没关系
Jake: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina:  薇薇
Katrina: Tasha.
Katrina:  昨天那个空调遥控器是不是在你那
Katrina: Was the air conditioner remote with you yesterday?
Katrina:  薇薇嗯遥控器
Katrina: Tasha, yeah, the remote.
Tasha: 不在我那
Tasha: It's not with me.
Tasha: 我说放在外面的桌上了
Tasha: I said I put it on the table outside.
Shure:  空调遥控器
Shure: The air conditioner remote.
Katrina:  2楼不通风有点热
Katrina: It's a bit hot on the second floor, not ventilated.
Katrina:  在这里
Katrina: Here it is.
Lucia: 这俩是同一个味吗
Lucia: Do these two have the same taste?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Tasha: 可能你加了之后
Tasha: Maybe after you added it,
Tasha: 我又不小心又加了一遍
Tasha: I accidentally added it again.
Lucia: 不不不
Lucia: No, no, no.
Lucia: 有哪位宝宝需要餐巾纸吗
Lucia: Does anyone need a napkin?
Tasha: 呃
Tasha: Uh.
Lucia: 需要吗
Lucia: Do you need one?
Tasha: 等一下就需要
Tasha: I'll need one in a bit.
Lucia: 那我先放在你这里
Lucia: Then I'll leave it with you first.
Tasha: 哦我这怎么了
Tasha: Oh, what's up with me?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Yeah.
Shure:  哦不
Shure: Oh no.
Alice: 下雪了
Alice: It's snowing.
Tasha: 大家够用吗
Tasha: Does everyone have enough?
Lucia: 要
Lucia: Yes.
Jake: 谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you.
Shure:  张万森下雪了
Shure: Zhang Wansen, it's snowing.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
Katrina:  我再来一张吧
Katrina: Let me take another one.
Lucia: 如果谁需要纸可以传递一下
Lucia: If anyone needs tissues, you can pass them around.
Shure:  是带那个
Shure: Is it the one with...
Shure:  洗洁精的湿巾是吗
Shure: ...dish soap wipes?
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Shure:  哈哈我擦擦
Shure: Haha, I'll wipe it off.
Alice: 对了
Alice: By the way...
Shure:  怎么感觉味不对
Shure: Why does it smell weird?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈再舔起泡了
Katrina: Haha, he's foaming again.
Lucia: 哎什么东西
Lucia: Hey, what's that?
Lucia: 带洗洁精
Lucia: With dish soap?
Alice: 那个厨房湿巾
Alice: It's the kitchen wipes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 咂嘴
Alice: Smack.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice: 一个宝贵的数据
Alice: A precious piece of data.
Shure:  哎我记得我刚才掉了一块肉在这
Shure: Hey, I remember I dropped a piece of meat here.
Shure:  怎么找不到了
Shure: Why can't I find it?
Jake: 掉什么了
Jake: What did you drop?
Jake: 掉披萨了啊
Jake: Did you drop a pizza?
Shure:  啊不是那个有一块
Shure: Ah, no, there was a piece...
Shure:  刚才掉了一块肉
Shure: ...a piece of meat I dropped earlier.
Shure:  我记得掉地下了
Shure: I remember it fell on the floor.
Shure:  掉下找不到了
Shure: Dropped and can't find it now.
Shure:  行了留给蟑螂先生了
Shure: Alright, it's left for Mr. Cockroach.
Lucia: 为什么你们
Lucia: Why do you...
Tasha: 每个盘都送的好均匀啊
Tasha: ...make every plate so evenly?
Shure:  一两个两个两个
Shure: One or two, two or two.
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This...
Katrina:  他俩不是一个
Katrina: They're not the same.
Alice: 所以这个是
Alice: So this is...
Katrina:  我要问一下他是讲新课还是讲复习课
Katrina: I need to ask if he's teaching a new lesson or a review.
Katrina:  这个得等他回来才知道
Katrina: We'll have to wait for him to come back to know.
Tasha: 要不要把整盒整盒
Tasha: Should we just put the whole box...
Jake: 好啊拼一拼
Jake: Sure, let's combine them.
Tasha: 这俩可以直接拼过来了
Tasha: These two can be combined directly.
Tasha: 把这个拼在一起
Tasha: Put these pieces together.
Tasha: 对这好像就差两块
Tasha: Yeah, we just need two more pieces.
Alice: 一家子一家子
Alice: All in the family, all in the family.
Jake: 这就是什么什么
Jake: This is like, um, what's it called...
Jake: 油泼面拌臊子面
Jake: Oil-splashed noodles mixed with minced meat noodles.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 必胜客经典二合一
Lucia: Pizza Hut's classic combo.
Jake: 这二合一确实很好
Jake: This combo is really good.
Lucia: 不行我现在站不起来了哈哈
Lucia: I can't stand up right now, haha.
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢好了
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you, all good.
Jake: 嗯挺好
Jake: Yeah, it's pretty good.
Tasha: 还好把榴莲的都吃完了
Tasha: Good thing we finished the durian.
Tasha: 不然他会污染别的味道
Tasha: Otherwise it would spoil the other flavors.
Lucia: 好热好热
Lucia: So hot, so hot.
Jake: 榴莲还是可以吃完的怎么了
Jake: Durian can still be finished, what's the problem?
Jake: 哦好热
Jake: Oh, it's so hot.
Lucia: 可能是二楼没有那么透气的
Lucia: Maybe the second floor isn't that well-ventilated.
Lucia: 稍等一下啊
Lucia: Wait a second.
Lucia: 对只有只有卧室的窗户好像能打开
Lucia: Yeah, it seems like only the bedroom window can be opened.
Lucia: 大厅的都打不开
Lucia: The hall windows can't be opened.
Alice: 想用一下
Alice: Want to use it?
Jake: 好收溜
Jake: Okay, let's clean up.
Jake: 收丢上礼物上链接
Jake: Clean up, send the gifts, and post the links.
Lucia: 这俩叠一块吧
Lucia: Stack these two together.
Shure:  这个改过的
Shure: This one has been modified.
Shure:  结构大概是这个样子
Shure: The structure looks like this.
Lucia: 我们的垃圾袋啊在那边
Lucia: Our trash bags are over there.
Lucia: good
Lucia: Good.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Katrina:  good
Katrina: Good.
Lucia: 等等我
Lucia: Wait for me.
Lucia: 好像已经好几天没有打卡
Lucia: I think I haven't checked in for days.
Lucia: 我的duolingo了
Lucia: On my Duolingo.
Jake: 学学什么呢
Jake: What are you learning?
Lucia: 德语
Lucia: German.
Jake: 德语
Jake: German?
Jake: 学德语干啥
Jake: Why learn German?
Lucia: 比较喜欢哦
Lucia: I just like it, oh.
Shure:  想带上我的一切
Shure: I want to take everything with me.
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then
Shure:  这是水是吧
Shure: This is water, right?
Shure:  20
Shure: 20
Shure:  不能
Shure: Can't
Alice: 还有纸吗
Alice: Do we have any paper left?
Shure:  逼着我喝水
Shure: Forcing me to drink water
Jake: 这个空了
Jake: This one's empty
Jake: duo lin go是不是你很久没上
Jake: Duo lin go, is it because you haven't logged in for a long time
Jake: 他就会把图标变得很丑
Jake: that it makes the icon look ugly?
Lucia: 呃对
Lucia: Uh, yeah
Jake: 就是就真的会很就变
Jake: So it really changes, right?
Jake: 会变吗你变了吗
Jake: Does it change for you?
Lucia: 会变
Lucia: It does change
Lucia: 就是如果说你好好久不去上课的话
Lucia: If you don't attend classes for a long time
Lucia: 他就会变成要么在睡觉的表情
Lucia: it either shows a sleeping face
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 要么就变成沙漠里的一个鸟骷髅
Lucia: or it turns into a bird skeleton in the desert
Jake: OK
Lucia: 然后如果你每天打卡的话
Lucia: And if you check in every day
Lucia: 他就会非常开心
Lucia: it'll be very happy
Lucia: 那个表情
Lucia: the expression
Lucia: 如果你某一天当天没有打卡
Lucia: But if you miss a day
Lucia: 他就会就是呈现一个怒火的表情哦
Lucia: it'll show an angry expression
Lucia: 真的很有意思
Lucia: It's really interesting
Jake: 是
Jake: Yes
Lucia: 我觉得我最大的乐趣不来自于学语言
Lucia: I think my biggest joy doesn't come from learning the language
Lucia: 来自于观赏他
Lucia: but from watching it
Lucia: 这个图标射程
Lucia: the icon shoot
Jake: 可以
Jake: Got it
Jake: 嗯管家什么时候
Jake: Hmm, when will the butler
Jake: 我也不知道管家什么时候
Jake: I don't know when the butler will
Jake: 问话要
Jake: ask questions
Shure:  我们现在是要交换礼物
Shure: Are we exchanging gifts now?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure:  好的走
Shure: Alright, let's go
Shure:  这个是运动会
Shure: This is the sports meet
Jake: 大伙看看自己眼镜还有多少电
Jake: Everyone check how much battery your glasses have left
Jake: 要不要插充电宝
Jake: Do you need to plug in a power bank?
Jake: 时间差不多了
Jake: It's almost time
Shure:  一直在挂着尿袋
Shure: Always hanging with a urine bag
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay
Shure:  我们吃了4个披萨
Shure: We ate four pizzas
Shure:  相当于是吧
Shure: Pretty much, right?
Shure:  对吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Shure:  7个人4个披萨
Shure: Seven people, four pizzas
Lucia: 4624
Lucia: 28 大概每个人吃了三四块的样子
Lucia: 28, so each person had about three or four slices
Lucia: 为什么要算
Lucia: Why are we calculating this?
Lucia: 条件反射的算一下
Lucia: Just instinctively calculating
Lucia: 估算一下大家的饭量以后好点
Lucia: Estimating everyone's meal size for the future
Shure:  之前还看过一个披萨笑话是
Shure: I once heard a pizza joke
Shure:  说披萨是最诚实的食物
Shure: They said pizza is the most honest food
Shure:  因为他没有欺骗
Shure: Because it never lies
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay
Lucia: 对不会
Lucia: Yeah, right
Lucia: 天呐谐音梗扣分哈哈哈
Lucia: Oh my, that's a pun deduction, haha
Lucia: 没有反应过来
Lucia: I didn't get it at first
Lucia: 这个我们要放冰箱或者怎么样吗
Lucia: Should we put this in the fridge or what?
Lucia: 还是就在外面放着就行
Lucia: Or just leave it out?
Lucia: 如果一会就用来picknick了
Lucia: If we're gonna use it for a picnic later
Shure:  先不用放冰箱了
Shure: No need to put it in the fridge for now
Alice: 不用放了下午不就拿走了
Alice: No need, we'll take it in the afternoon
Tasha: 我这怎么3.8块钱
Tasha: Why is mine 3.8 yuan?
Jake: 放这吧
Jake: Just leave it here
Shure:  阴凉遮光无光处对
Shure: In a cool, shaded place, away from light
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 嗯好再打一下我们又可以吃了
Lucia: Okay, once we heat it up, we can eat again
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice: 这个是多出来的
Alice: This is extra
Alice: 要搁那吗
Alice: Should we put it there?
Shure:  是的哈哈哈
Shure: Yes, hahaha
Jake: 子棠我们再看一下充电宝吧
Jake: Nicous, let's check the power bank again
Jake: 对你你查
Jake: Yeah, you check
Jake: 再看一下
Jake: Check again
Shure:  这是重要素材
Shure: This is important material
Shure:  所以不可丢不可遗失
Shure: So it cannot be lost
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Alice: 我一般就是他那种呃
Alice: I'm usually like him, uh
Alice: 48小时24小时之内发货的
Alice: Ships within 48 hours or 24 hours.
Alice: 我就买了
Alice: Then I'll buy it.
Alice: 买不到到不了就退了
Alice: If I can't buy it or it doesn't arrive, I'll return it.
Lucia: 要不因为我在淘宝上看到了
Lucia: Because I saw it on Taobao.
Lucia: 我的那些渔网什么的
Lucia: Those fishing nets and stuff.
Lucia: 我觉得还挺合适的
Lucia: I think they are quite suitable.
Lucia: 那我还是淘宝上买算了
Lucia: So I might as well buy it on Taobao.
Alice: 呃
Alice: Uh...
Lucia: 这是用来装饰房间的
Lucia: This is for decorating the room.
Shure:  渔网
Shure: Fishing nets.
Katrina:  捕梦网是不是
Katrina: Dreamcatchers, right?
Lucia: 哦没有就是
Lucia: Oh, no, it's...
Lucia: 是对但是跟海有关
Lucia: Yes, but related to the sea.
Lucia: 就我想的是
Lucia: What I have in mind is...
Lucia: 可能做成地中海风格的那种
Lucia: Maybe make it Mediterranean style.
Lucia: 蓝白的颜色
Lucia: Blue and white colors.
Lucia: 但我发现我现在买的材料都是白的
Lucia: But I found out the materials I bought are all white.
Lucia: 还没有蓝材料呢
Lucia: There's no blue material yet.
Alice: 如果你想做地中海风格
Alice: If you want to do Mediterranean style,
Alice: 我可以把高中的老师捐给你
Alice: I can donate my high school teacher to you.
Lucia: 把高中老师捐给我
Lucia: Donate your high school teacher to me?
Lucia: 为什么
Lucia: Why?
Alice: 因为他是个地中海啊
Alice: Because he's Mediterranean.
Jake: 那我再说
Jake: Let me say it again.
Jake: 你还有电吗
Jake: Do you still have power?
Alice: 露西呀你还有电吗
Alice: Lucia, do you still have power?
Lucia: 嗯你在问我吗
Lucia: Hmm, are you asking me?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Tasha: 这个在录着呢
Tasha: This is still recording.
Jake: 你你你插掉
Jake: You, you, you unplug it.
Tasha: 直接插掉就行吗
Tasha: Just unplug it?
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 还有60%
Tasha: It's at 60%.
Jake: 嗯行可以
Jake: Hmm, okay, that's fine.
Shure:  你看那个磁吸压到头发了
Shure: Look, the magnet is pulling your hair.
Lucia: 我打算把那个串珠还是买一串
Lucia: I plan to buy a string of those beads.
Lucia: 好吧如果他来得及到
Lucia: Alright, if they arrive on time,
Lucia: 咱可能还能做一下那个水母灯
Lucia: we might be able to make that jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 再来点欧根纱
Lucia: And add some organza.
Alice: 我本来昨天想买的
Alice: I was planning to buy it yesterday.
Alice: 然后发现跟我的啊
Alice: Then I found out it matched mine.
Lucia: 啊我打算买一米的蓝色欧根纱
Lucia: Oh, I'm planning to buy a meter of blue organza.
Lucia: 我可以在房间里面弄一下
Lucia: I can do something with it in the room.
Lucia: 然后剩下的就你如如果就算真的要做灯
Lucia: And if you really want to make a lamp,
Lucia: 它里面用的纱也很少
Lucia: It doesn't use much fabric inside.
Lucia: 就我们每个人可以弄一块
Lucia: Each of us can use a piece,
Lucia: 然后放在里面
Lucia: And put it inside.
Alice: 然后给他剪掉
Alice: Then cut it off for him.
Lucia: 对对就比较好看一些
Lucia: Yes, it will look better that way.
Alice: 边角料可以旋转一下固定一下
Alice: The leftover pieces can be twisted and fixed,
Alice: 然后贴贴
Alice: Then stick them.
Alice: 贴在什么地方
Alice: Stick them somewhere.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 我觉得你昨天安利给我的那个桌布
Lucia: I think the tablecloth you recommended yesterday,
Lucia: 真的很好看
Lucia: Is really nice.
Alice: 嗯我也我也买桌布了
Alice: Yeah, I bought a tablecloth too.
Jake: 桌布桌布挂墙上
Jake: Tablecloth on the wall.
Lucia: 不是啦
Lucia: No, no.
Lucia: 桌布当然是放在桌子上
Lucia: Tablecloths are for tables, obviously.
Jake: 你们有桌子吗
Jake: Do you guys have a table?
Alice: 我有一个小的
Alice: I have a small one.
Lucia: 他有小桌子
Lucia: He has a small table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice: 四十乘
Alice: Forty by...
Lucia: 我打算配一个塑料的小方桌
Lucia: I'm planning to get a small plastic square table.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 就会能轻一点
Lucia: It will be lighter.
Lucia: 也不是很贵
Lucia: And not too expensive.
Lucia: 因为我那个架子实在是太丑了
Lucia: Because my current shelf is just too ugly.
Jake: 明白
Jake: Got it.
Lucia: 无法改造我觉得
Lucia: It's beyond saving, I think.
Alice: 我觉得我们这个户型还挺好的
Alice: I think our layout is pretty good.
Alice: 因为比较小就
Alice: Because it's small, so...
Shure:  往下东西
Shure: Things go down.
Lucia: 对对
Lucia: Right, right.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 哎东西呢
Alice: Hey, where are the things?
Jake: 我们也整点喝的吧
Jake: Let's get something to drink too.
Jake: 哈哈给给您倒点咖咖啡给您倒点水
Jake: Haha, let me pour you some coffee, or water.
Shure:  谢谢
Shure: Thanks
Katrina:  这咖啡吗
Katrina: Is this coffee?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Katrina:  这好像昨天晚上调的
Katrina: This seems like it was made last night.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: This is the one.
Jake: 这些应该都用过
Jake: These should have all been used.
Jake: 来吧我们
Jake: Come on, let's...
Jake: 我们最后一名做到
Jake: Let's get the last one done.
Katrina:  我怎么做到老板
Katrina: How do I do it, boss?
Alice: 最后一名
Alice: The last one.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake: 我也不做
Jake: I'm not doing it either.
Jake: 就是呃我们最后一名开始
Jake: So, um, we start with the last one...
Jake: 呃介绍自己的礼物然后第一名
Jake: Uh, introducing their gift, and then the first one...
Jake: 呃大家秀一轮之后然后第一名开始挑
Jake: Uh, after everyone shows their gift, the first one gets to pick.
Jake: 对对对我们排名了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, we've ranked everyone.
Jake: 我们有电量96的
Jake: We have a score of 96.
Alice: 到1-2
Alice: To 1-2.
Alice: 嗯我在你后边
Alice: Hmm, I'm behind you.
Tasha: 呃我不知道
Tasha: Uh, I don't know.
Tasha: 写了一个东西
Tasha: Wrote something...
Tasha: 乱七八糟的东西
Tasha: A bunch of random stuff.
Jake: 笑口常开
Jake: Keep smiling.
Tasha: 明信片
Tasha: Postcard.
Shure:  天下粮仓
Shure: Grain warehouse.
Tasha: 种植套餐
Tasha: Planting kit.
Katrina:  呵呵呵
Katrina: Hehehe
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This...
Tasha: 营养塔
Tasha: Nutrition tower.
Tasha: 营养土盆栽和培养米种这张卡片的
Tasha: Nutrient soil, potted plants, and breeding rice seeds, this card...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Shure:  这鼓好用吗
Shure: Is this drum useful?
Katrina:  把这摆着
Katrina: Put this here.
Jake: 不要太玩
Jake: Don't play too much.
Tasha: 好了
Tasha: Alright.
Lucia: 你说这个鼓吗
Lucia: Are you talking about this drum?
Katrina:  不是  蛊  虫子下蛊了
Katrina: No, not the drum. It's a curse with insects.
Lucia: OK OK
Lucia: OK, OK.
Shure:  这个怎么翻译成英文
Shure: How do you translate this into English?
Katrina:  100人就开始算塔罗了
Katrina: Start doing tarot readings for 100 people.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What’s this?
Tasha: 营养土啊
Tasha: Nutrient soil.
Lucia: 是椰土那种吗
Lucia: Is it coconut soil?
Tasha: 啊啊
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 香菇是长
Jake: Mushrooms grow...
Jake: 香菇是好
Jake: Mushrooms are good...
Tasha: 可以养狼蛛用
Tasha: You can use it to raise tarantulas.
Lucia: sorry狼蛛
Lucia: Sorry, tarantulas?
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 对就是养狼蛛是要垫椰土的
Lucia: Yeah, you need coconut soil to raise tarantulas.
Alice: 你有这爱好
Alice: You have this hobby?
Lucia: 我现在没养
Lucia: I don't keep them now.
Lucia: 我以前养过
Lucia: I used to.
Lucia: 但是
Lucia: But...
Jake: 你多大呀
Jake: How old are you?
Lucia: 被我养死了哈哈哈
Lucia: I let them die, haha.
Lucia: 呃4只宠物
Lucia: Uh, four pets.
Lucia: 那个岂不是狼蛛不舍他们偷吃养的
Lucia: Isn't it just the tarantulas who don’t share their food?
Jake: 啊倒第二
Jake: Ah, second to last.
Jake: 倒数第二名
Jake: Second to last place.
Jake: 第二名吧
Jake: Second place, right?
Jake: 第二名
Jake: Second place.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice: 准备了一个手链
Alice: I prepared a bracelet.
Alice: 是帝王沙跟绿松石的哦
Alice: It’s made of sandstone and turquoise.
Alice: 朱砂
Alice: Cinnabar.
Alice: 就是古代皇帝批折子用的那个红色的那个颜料就是从这边提取的
Alice: The red pigment that ancient emperors used to write with was extracted from this.
Alice: 然后绿松石就是蓝绿色
Alice: And turquoise is blue-green.
Alice: 因为有铜跟铁的那些
Alice: Because it has copper and iron in it.
Alice: 哎不是铜
Alice: Oh, not copper.
Jake: 啥
Jake: What?
Alice: 铜跟
Alice: Copper and...
Shure:  朱砂
Shure: Cinnabar.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice: 铜跟豆铜跟铁
Alice: Copper and, um, iron.
Alice: 然后他这个会呈现不同的颜色
Alice: So it shows different colors.
Alice: 主要是我觉得朱砂比较辟邪
Alice: Mostly, I think cinnabar is good for warding off evil.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice: 是这样
Alice: That's right.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 谁电量多来着啊
Jake: Who has the most battery left?
Shure:  啊我我我最老
Shure: Ah, me, me, I'm the oldest.
Jake: 你多少来着
Jake: How much do you have?
Shure:  我是十几
Shure: I have over ten percent.
Shure:  好像
Shure: I think.
Jake: 挺好哎
Jake: That's great!
Jake: 你这啥玩意
Jake: What's that thing?
Shure:  这个是一个乐器
Shure: This is a musical instrument.
Shure:  它是一个叫做沙球的乐器
Shure: It's called a shaker.
Tasha: 原来这个放到这一直就是你的呀
Tasha: So this has been yours all along?
Katrina:  哈哈哈已经被玩过了
Katrina: Haha, it's already been played with.
Shure:  已经被大家玩坏了
Shure: It's been played with by everyone.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure:  然后他可以这个样子
Shure: And you can do it like this.
Tasha: 然后呢
Tasha: And then?
Shure:  这是他的沙球作用
Shure: This is its shaker function.
Shure:  然后他还可以
Shure: And then it can also...
Shure:  就是比如说
Shure: For example...
Shure:  就是它会发出一些碰撞的声音
Shure: It can make some collision sounds.
Shure:  对然后
Shure: Yeah, and...
Tasha: AMSR啊哈哈
Tasha: AMSR, haha.
Shure:  最最最酷炫的就是它可以摆起来
Shure: The coolest thing is it can stand up.
Tasha: 好酷哈哈
Tasha: So cool, haha.
Shure:  然后配合摆动
Shure: And with the shaking...
Shure:  再加上一些
Shure: Plus some...
Katrina:  摇滚的东西
Katrina: Rock elements.
Shure:  一些一点点魔法
Shure: A bit of magic.
Shure:  然后就可以打出不一样的节奏型
Shure: Then you can play different rhythms.
Shure:  就比如说像这个样子
Shure: For example, like this.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jake: 来一段
Jake: Play something.
Shure:  这是来一段
Shure: This is playing something.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 我以为你叫什么大大节了
Jake: I thought you were playing something big.
Lucia: 不应该来点这个才艺表演吗
Lucia: Shouldn't there be some talent show?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  竹板这么一打呀
Shure: As the bamboo clappers strike...
Shure:  别的咱不夸
Shure: We won't praise anything else.
Shure:  咱就夸夸咱那个狗不理包子
Shure: Let's talk about how awesome those Goubuli buns are.
Shure:  哈哈这一种赛博快板吧
Shure: Haha, it's like a cyber quick talk.
Shure:  可能非洲人的快板就是长这个样子
Shure: Maybe African quick talk looks like this.
Shure:  哈哈哈这确实好像是一种非洲的乐器
Shure: Haha, this does seem like some kind of African instrument.
Jake: OK
Shure:  他的学名我忘了叫啥了
Shure: I forgot the scientific name for it.
Shure:  反正大家都叫它砂锤啊砂球
Shure: Anyway, people call it a shaker or sand hammer.
Shure:  然后这是一个静音的
Shure: And this one is a muted version.
Shure:  就是它就是这种橡木的
Shure: It's made of oak.
Shure:  然后正常可能会有那种金属的
Shure: Normally, it might be made of metal.
Shure:  或者塑料的
Shure: Or plastic.
Shure:  就是音色是不一样的
Shure: So the sound is different.
Shure:  这个就比较不那么吵
Shure: This one isn't as noisy.
Shure:  然后声音也稍微暖一些
Shure: And the sound is a bit warmer.
Shure:  然后送出一个留一个
Shure: I'll keep one and give one away.
Shure:  因为演出还需要用的
Shure: Because we still need it for performances.
Shure:  哈哈哈不能把吃饭家伙事丢了
Shure: Haha, can't lose the tools we make a living with.
Jake: 你是什么演出要用
Jake: What kind of performances do you need it for?
Shure:  就一些现场的演出也会用到的
Shure: We use it for some live performances.
Jake: 哈哈就煮饭啊
Jake: Haha, just for cooking.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  制造一种氛围音的时候
Shure: When creating atmospheric sounds.
Lucia: 好像ASMR啊
Lucia: Like ASMR, huh?
Shure:  我再配合这手链给你
Shure: I'll match it with this bracelet for you.
Katrina:  睡了
Katrina: Fell asleep.
Tasha: 睡了
Tasha: Fell asleep.
Lucia: 困了困了
Lucia: Getting sleepy.
Alice: 摇酒天赋
Alice: Shaking skills.
Shure:  嗯好哈哈哈好
Shure: Hmm, alright, haha, alright.
Katrina:  然后介绍我的吧
Katrina: Now let me introduce mine.
Katrina:  我就是前前前一段时间去成都玩
Katrina: I went to Chengdu a while ago.
Katrina:  然后去那个玉林路那一些古着店
Katrina: And went to some vintage stores on Yulin Road.
Katrina:  淘的一些
Katrina: Found some stuff.
Katrina:  呃就是钥匙扣和胸针
Katrina: Like keychains and brooches.
Shure:  就是淘宝店淘的新东西是吗
Shure: So you found new stuff in a Taobao shop?
Shure:  哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Katrina:  对淘就是他他那个开店那个店主
Katrina: Yeah, the shop owner designs them.
Katrina:  他们是自己设计的
Katrina: They have their own design studio.
Katrina:  就是自己是一个设计工作室
Katrina: They create their own designs.
Katrina:  然后就只有在他
Katrina: And then only at his...
Katrina:  们那里能买到
Katrina: ...place you can buy it.
Katrina:  然后买的是大熊猫的大熊猫
Katrina: And what you get is a big panda, a giant panda.
Katrina:  这是钥匙扣
Katrina: This is a keychain.
Katrina:  这是一个胸针
Katrina: And this is a brooch.
Katrina:  就是一个鸟和一个猫
Katrina: It's a bird and a cat.
Katrina:  我也不知道什么意思
Katrina: I don't know what it means either.
Katrina:  我只是觉得很可爱
Katrina: I just thought it was cute.
Katrina:  我就买回来送给大家
Katrina: So I bought it to give to everyone.
Katrina:  好OK
Katrina: Alright, okay.
Alice: Lucy
Jake: 好96
Jake: Alright, 96.
Katrina:  嗯抽口的话对这里面有一个marry me
Katrina: Well, if you draw this, there's a "marry me" inside.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 不是marry me
Lucia: Not "marry me."
Lucia: 就是我本来是就是有一个小手做的耳钉
Lucia: Actually, I originally had a pair of earrings made by a little hand.
Lucia: 然后对这个其实很简单
Lucia: And yeah, it's actually pretty simple.
Lucia: 就只要买打了孔的珠子
Lucia: You just need to buy some beads with holes in them
Lucia: 和这个这个耳针
Lucia: And these ear studs
Lucia: 然后拿热熔胶把它粘在一起就可以
Lucia: Then you just use hot glue to stick them together
Lucia: 对然后但是就是我我自己做完之后
Lucia: Yeah, so after I made them myself
Lucia: 我觉得这个还那个效果还挺好
Lucia: I thought they turned out pretty well
Lucia: 所以我做了好几对
Lucia: So I made several pairs
Lucia: 然后刚好就是这边要给大家
Lucia: And since I needed to prepare gifts for everyone
Lucia: 就是给大家准备礼物
Lucia: I made one for that
Lucia: 我就准备了一个
Lucia: I feel like handmade gifts are more meaningful
Lucia: 感觉是自己的手做的话会比较有意义
Lucia: But why did I buy a drawer?
Lucia: 但是为什么我又去买了一个抽屉呢
Lucia: Because I found the box a bit big
Lucia: 因为我发现这个盒子有点大
Lucia: When I put them in the box
Lucia: 当我把它放到这盒子里面的时候
Lucia: They looked really lonely
Lucia: 他们俩显得非常的孤单
Lucia: 然后我为了增加开盒的时候的气势
Lucia: So to make the unboxing more impressive
Lucia: 我就又去买了一个抽壳放在里面
Lucia: I bought another drawer to put inside
Lucia: 然后但这样一放
Lucia: But when I did that
Lucia: 就会完全挡住他们两个
Lucia: It completely covered them
Lucia: 所以就是对
Lucia: So yeah
Lucia: 于是这个礼物
Lucia: That’s the gift
Lucia: 就变成了一个复合装饰的样子
Lucia: 然后这个就很就是这个
Lucia: And then this is just, you know, this.
Lucia: 我觉得还蛮好看的
Lucia: I think it's pretty good looking.
Lucia: 因为它是那种丝绒的料
Lucia: Because it's made of velvet material.
Lucia: 就是穿很多裙子都可以搭配
Lucia: It can go well with many dresses.
Lucia: 但是男孩子的话就不考虑了
Lucia: But for boys, it's not really an option.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  行了
Shure: Alright.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure:  你怎么能定定义我
Shure: How can you define me like that?
Lucia: 对不起对不起我错了啊
Lucia: I'm sorry, I'm sorry, it was my mistake.
Shure:  我就是你看正好两个嘛
Shure: Look, there are exactly two.
Alice: 哦
Alice: Oh.
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Lucia: 没有想到这一次
Lucia: Didn't expect that this time.
Lucia: 那那那说明你也是可以试用的
Lucia: It means you can also try it out.
Lucia: 那大家挑选起来就没有顾虑
Lucia: So everyone can choose without worries.
Alice: 对呵
Alice: Yes, hehe.
Shure:  好话都
Shure: All the good things.
Shure:  让你说完了
Shure: You've said them all.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Alright then.
Jake: 那路亚开始
Jake: Let's start picking.
Lucia: 这
Lucia: This.
Jake: 这怎么挑的
Jake: How did you pick it?
Lucia: 我以为是盲挑来着
Lucia: I thought it was a blind pick.
Jake: 咱盲挑
Jake: Let's blind pick.
Lucia: 感觉都很有特色的样子
Lucia: They all seem quite unique.
Shure:  先说一句好话
Shure: Say something nice first.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  憋出来了
Katrina: You're holding it in.
Jake: 那咱要不盲挑也可以要不
Jake: So, should we blind pick or not?
Lucia: 我我我摇个骰子吧
Lucia: I'll roll a dice then.
Lucia: 那就要不
Lucia: So, should we?
Shure:  行
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 嗯可以抽到我自己怎么办
Lucia: Hmm, what if I pick myself?
Katrina:  一二
Katrina: One, two.
Alice: 再来一轮
Alice: Let's go another round.
Katrina:  4
Katrina: Four.
Shure:  1234 对咱们
Shure: One, two, three, four, right, we.
Lucia: 对咱们
Lucia: Right, we.
Lucia: 咱们的群呢
Lucia: Our group.
Lucia: 我放到我就在咱们群里摇好了
Lucia: I'll post it in our group and roll it there.
Shure:  公平公正公开
Shure: Fair and square.
Shure:  sorry
Shure: Sorry.
Katrina:  特别可爱是不是
Katrina: So cute, right?
Jake: 直播摇骰子
Jake: Live dice rolling.
Lucia: 2 我结果大家能看得到吗
Lucia: 2, can everyone see my result?
Lucia: 发了一个
Lucia: Sent one.
Tasha: 看到了
Tasha: I see it.
Alice: 二
Alice: Two.
Lucia: 二
Lucia: Two.
Alice: 谁是2
Alice: Who is 2?
Lucia: 按介绍说明
Lucia: According to the instructions.
Alice: 我是2
Alice: I'm 2.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 谢谢可馨
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Lucia: 啊这个包装也好好看
Lucia: Oh, this packaging looks so nice.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 色子是在表情里吗
Lucia: The dice are in the emojis, right?
Jake: 好
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  表情里
Katrina: In the emojis.
Jake: 那我们第二
Jake: Then we pick the second.
Jake: 第二名来挑
Jake: The second place picks.
Jake: 倒数第二名来挑
Jake: The second-to-last place picks.
Shure:  哈哈你挑的你都都不那什么了
Shure: Haha, you chose, and then you just disappear without saying anything.
Shure:  客套话都不说直接闪了
Shure: No polite words, just gone.
Katrina:  我
Katrina: I...
Katrina:  哈哈迫不及待啊
Katrina: Haha, can't wait, huh?
Katrina:  会直接搜筛子
Katrina: You can search dice directly.
Jake: 这是真色子 假色子每次都能摇6
Jake: This is a real die. Fake ones always roll a 6.
Shure:  哎你这是固定三的
Shure: Hey, yours always rolls a 3.
Katrina:  真假
Katrina: No way.
Katrina:  什么叫固定3
Katrina: What's a fixed 3?
Jake: 那再再忍一下你自己
Jake: Hold on, try it yourself.
Shure:  一二哎
Shure: One, two, hey.
Shure:  不是3是我  3是我
Shure: It's not 3, it's me. 3 is me.
Jake: 等一下我再再再摇一下看是固定的吗
Jake: Wait, let me roll it again to see if it's fixed.
Alice: 不是吧不是
Alice: No way, no way.
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Jake: OK那那行那行
Jake: OK, alright, that's fine.
Katrina:  还是3
Katrina: Still 3.
Lucia: 还是3
Lucia: Still 3
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey
Shure:  你没有表这个表情吗
Shure: Don't you have that expression?
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh
Jake: 咬出一个亿
Jake: Bite out a billion
Lucia: 哦咬出一个亿
Lucia: Oh bite out a billion
Katrina:  给我自己
Katrina: For myself
Shure:  那就3吧
Shure: Then let's go with 3
Jake: 就三三好
Jake: Yeah, 3 is good
Shure:  唉
Shure: Sigh
Katrina:  哈哈哈每天晚上你会听到我在房间
Katrina: Hahaha every night you'll hear me in the room
Shure:  没事我在你楼下
Shure: It's fine, I'm downstairs
Jake: 好那到你摇吧
Jake: Alright, now it's your turn to shake
Jake: 你倒啊
Jake: Go ahead
Shure:  我我摇吧还是
Shure: Should I shake it or...
Jake: 你客套话呢
Jake: Don't be so polite
Shure:  客套话就是
Shure: Being polite means...
Katrina:  谢谢大家
Katrina: Thank you everyone
Shure:  大家每个都非常的棒
Shure: Everyone did really great
Shure:  然后呢
Shure: And then...
Shure:  让我实在难以割舍
Shure: It's really hard for me to let go
Shure:  选哪个割舍其他的
Shure: To choose one and let go of the others
Shure:  都是一种
Shure: It's all...
Katrina:  演上了
Katrina: He's acting
Shure:  我是几 四
Shure: What's my number, 4?
Shure:  1234 呀
Shure: 1234, right?
Katrina:  呀
Katrina: Yep
Katrina:  这么可爱的送给你
Katrina: This cuteness is for you
Shure:  哪有
Shure: No way
Katrina:  送给你哈哈送给你
Katrina: For you, haha, for you
Shure:  好
Shure: Alright
Lucia: 达成了交换
Lucia: The trade is done
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Jake: 那我们
Jake: So we...
Shure:  剩下二位就变成交换了
Shure: The remaining two will make a trade
Alice: 好
Alice: Okay
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay
Alice: 你得给我
Alice: You have to give it to me
Alice: 然后他再给你
Alice: Then he will give it to you
Tasha: 我知道
Tasha: I know
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks
Shure:  完了
Shure: It's over
Shure:  没抽到洋鼓很可惜
Shure: It's a pity we didn't get the drum
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Jake: 那就收拾收拾准备出发
Jake: Let's pack up and get ready to go
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay
Katrina:  你这个要导数据吗
Katrina: Do you need to export the data?
Jake: 要
Jake: Yes
Katrina:  你之前要倒一会啊
Katrina: How long do you need to export it?
Tasha: 这钱我也不知道怎么啊
Tasha: I don't know what to do with this money
Tasha: 就是好看
Tasha: It's just pretty
Shure:  卡掉
Shure: It got stuck
Jake: 呃先先带回带回去
Jake: Uh, first, let's take it back
Jake: 然后带到一楼
Jake: And then bring it to the first floor
Jake: 放到那个
Jake: Put it in the
Tasha: 你可以把它
Tasha: You can put it
Jake: 盒里边
Jake: In the box
Tasha: 那个是书法课上面老师
Tasha: The teacher bought it for the calligraphy class
Tasha: 呃统一买的
Tasha: Uh, bought it in bulk
Lucia: 哦可以好奇一下写的什么
Lucia: Oh, can I be curious about what's written?
Alice: 笑口常开
Alice: Keep smiling
Lucia: 哇好好看啊
Lucia: Wow, it's so beautiful
Lucia: 写的好好
Lucia: It's written so well
Alice: 回眸
Alice: Glancing back
Jake: 啊谁写的
Jake: Ah, who wrote this?
Jake: 你写的哦
Jake: Did you write it?
Lucia: 微微写的
Lucia: Vivi wrote it
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh
Lucia: 好好看
Lucia: It's so beautiful
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome
Shure:  是不是有点太短了
Shure: Isn't it a bit too short?
Alice: 也差不多
Alice: It's about right
Jake: 好看
Jake: Looks good
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake: 就大家把礼物放到自己房间
Jake: Everyone, put your gifts in your rooms
Jake: 然后下去再一起结束就结束了
Jake: Then come down, and we'll wrap things up together
Katrina:  放到自己的房间
Katrina: Put it in your room
Alice: 是上一年
Alice: It was last year
Alice: 去年冬天写的
Alice: Written last winter
Tasha: 对哎我
Tasha: Yeah, I
Jake: 我跳舞了
Jake: I danced.
Alice: 今年是甲醛
Alice: This year is formaldehyde.
Jake: 在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: Dancing outside, looking back.
Shure:  回眸
Shure: Looking back.
Jake: 你们得在外面跳舞回眸
Jake: You guys need to dance outside and look back.
Jake: 然后拍拍照
Jake: Then take some photos.
Jake: 拍完照最后一天放PPT
Jake: After taking the photos, we'll show the PPT on the last day.
Alice: 我念对念惯了
Alice: I'm used to reciting it correctly.
Shure:  这样呢应该是
Shure: Well, it should be like this.
Jake: 对就是pick lick是跳舞对吧
Jake: Yeah, pick lick means dancing, right?
Jake: 准备好防晒准备好
Jake: Get the sunscreen ready, be prepared.
Shure:  玩吧
Shure: Let's play.
Jake: 呃拍拍照准备最后一天放PPT准备好
Jake: Uh, take photos, get ready for the last day to show the PPT, be prepared.
Jake: 对就是手机拍拍照
Jake: Yeah, just take photos with your phone.
Lucia: 为什么我会砸到我自己的手
Lucia: Why do I keep hitting my own hand?
Shure:  因为它长
Shure: Because it's long.
Shure:  哦不不不就是夹的
Shure: Oh no, it's just clamped.
Jake: 呃对OK
Jake: Uh, yeah, okay.
Jake: 然后准备买肉
Jake: Then get ready to buy meat.
Lucia: 不行我还是会砸到自己的手
Lucia: No, I still keep hitting my own hand.
Jake: 晚上还有烤串
Jake: There's also kebabs tonight.
Jake: BBQ晚上烤串加甜点
Jake: BBQ, kebabs, and dessert tonight.
Tasha: 下午是要出去吗
Tasha: Are we going out in the afternoon?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Can we?
Katrina:  晚上还有披萨
Katrina: There's also pizza tonight.
Katrina:  两个够了不用再点
Katrina: Two is enough, no need to order more.
Jake: 这下午茶是披萨
Jake: This afternoon tea is pizza.
Jake: 可能在外边你们走累了吃俩披萨
Jake: Maybe after walking outside, you guys can eat two pizzas.
Katrina:  哦你说让披萨带
Katrina: Oh, you mean to take the pizza outside.
Katrina:  出去
Katrina: Outside.
Jake: 可以吧
Jake: Can we?
Katrina:  可以
Katrina: Sure.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina:  我得换件衣服
Katrina: I need to change clothes.
Katrina:  我得装这个东西没口袋
Katrina: I need to pack this stuff, no pockets.
Katrina:  装裤子
Katrina: Pack pants.
Shure:  确实很治愈
Shure: It's really healing.
Shure:  来杨老板坐这
Shure: Come sit here, Jake.
Shure:  我给你治愈一下
Shure: Let me heal you a bit.
Shure:  哎呦哎呦
Shure: Ouch, ouch.
Lucia: 给你听个现场的鲜花
Lucia: I'll let you hear some live flowers.
Jake: 环绕声是吧
Jake: Surround sound, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  一般拿个颂锅先duang
Shure: Usually, you take a pot first and duang.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 还是双摄
Lucia: Still double-camera.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake: 挺好水平挺高
Jake: Pretty good, high level.
Jake: 自带混响
Jake: Comes with reverb.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈这视频可以录吗
Lucia: Haha, can we record this video?
Lucia: 晚上睡觉的时候就用来助眠用
Lucia: Use it for sleep aid at night.
Jake: 可以你这卖钱吗
Jake: Sure, are you selling this?
Jake: 你要不你录一段
Jake: Why don't you record a segment?
Jake: 卖钱
Jake: Sell it.
Lucia: 你开一个
Lucia: You start one.
Jake: 卖多少钱
Jake: How much will you sell it for?
Lucia: AMSR频道
Lucia: AMSR channel.
Jake: 这个卖多少钱
Jake: How much does this sell for?
Shure:  不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake: 你这个掉了
Jake: You dropped this.
Shure:  我这个可以摘了
Shure: I can take this off.
Shure:  应该
Shure: Should be.
Jake: 行啊
Jake: Alright.
Shure:  是要导数据的是吧
Shure: Do we need to transfer the data?
Jake: 走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice: 现在就导吗
Alice: Transfer now?
Jake: 对他们把东西放回房间
Jake: Yes, they put the stuff back in the room.
Jake: 然后把眼镜给解决
Jake: Then handle the glasses.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then we finish.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 放回去
Jake: Put it back.
Jake: 然后再结束
Jake: Then we finish.
Jake: 再都
Jake: Then all...
Shure:  忘拿了
Shure: Almost forgot.
Shure:  差点
Shure: Nearly.
Jake: 不是放回去到下面一起结束这么回事
Jake: No, put it back, and then we finish everything together.
Shure:  好OK
Shure: Alright, OK.
Shure:  最近还是一样努力着
Shure: Recently, still working hard as usual.
Katrina:  这会不会放干燥的地方
Katrina: Should we put this in a dry place?
Katrina:  他会压干压花吸水更快
Katrina: It will press and dry the flowers faster.
Katrina:  今天再做一版看看
Katrina: Let's make another batch today.
Katrina:  就是第一天不是多了几朵花吗
Katrina: Remember we had a few extra flowers on the first day?
Katrina:  就把它剪下来压一下
Katrina: Let's cut them and press them.
Katrina:  看效果怎么样
Katrina: See how it turns out.
Katrina:  因为他有两天的时间
Katrina: Because we have two days.
Katrina:  我要提前试验一下
Katrina: I want to test it in advance.
Lucia: 看看什么时候停止呢
Lucia: Let's see when to stop.
Jake: 哎呀哈哈
Jake: Oh, haha.
Jake: 紫堂准备开工
Jake: Violet, get ready to start.
Shure:  再见杨老板
Shure: Goodbye, Jake.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake: 子堂开工
Jake: Violet, start working.
Katrina:  哎真好
Katrina: Oh, nice.
Jake: 嗯开工
Jake: Yes, start working.
Jake: 对开工
Shure:  然后我们
Shure: Then we...
Shure:  我们停掉
Shure: We'll stop.
Katrina:  是我的
Katrina: It's mine.
Jake: 呃停OK
Jake: Uh, stop, okay.
Jake: 行停掉
Jake: Alright, stop.
Jake: 停掉停掉
Jake: Stop, stop.
Alice: 停掉了
Alice: Stopped.
Jake: 停掉然后
Jake: Stop, and then...
Jake: 哎让他等我们倒吧
Jake: Hey, let him wait for us to finish.
Alice: done
Alice: Done.